hello je suis le styliste pour me
trouver tu rentres dans l'appli
messenger et utam le styliste dû cliquer
sur démarrer pour que notre aventure
commence
[Musique]
je t'attends rejoint vite sur messenger
et rory là il a un bras il arbres
exceptionnels
voilà et ben voilà et ben voilà c'est
pas facile ton truc là bas n'ont pas pu
aller en deux points
c'est parti seul sur le sable les yeux
dans l'eau suis jamais fait battre par
amy concours kilomètres à peine et 1 000
ml et gazier howlett monsieur alpha tu
joues les voir comme vous voulez les
champions de volley à aller ce nom
à 27 ans la halle et variant de zéro là
la dernière fois la dernière fois mario
aurait perdu là marion c'est un de mes
matches et plus difficiles que j'ai eu
au monde du ping pong et les motifs
attention c'est marion jours en tout cas
ce que je vois c'est que j'ai des amis
autour de la table s'il l'a fait beau
aujourd'hui ou pas
attention attention prêtant attention
elle est pour fêter ce premier projet
open rizzoli tintin à ses pas on y va à
0 marion et il est chiant à jouer mais
il est chiant tout court est parti je me
sens bien il avoue ne pas croire c'est
moi qui fais les règles - entre bâle et
2,0 d'accord allez voilà c'est la
dernière un double oui il est injouable
voulait faire un jeu qui arrive et voilà
[Applaudissements]